[Music]
my silver
Cheeta latamuda everybody one punch man
season 2 trailer we got to break it down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
the release date is kind of ambiguous it
just says April 2019 so we'll probably
get a more specific date when we get a
little bit closer but part of the reason
why I think it's taken so long to get
here is because they switched animation
studios so viz media is handling season
two and this is them that cut this
trailer trying to show everybody oh you
know we want to do something really
special so there's only that little
teaser for Goro that gives you an idea
for what some of their animation might
end up looking like maybe early next
year at the latest but most of you might
be at least a little bit familiar with
the manga but Goro is probably what's
going to be the fulfillment of this
prophecy like at the end of season one
they have the culmination of this arc
with the dark matter thieves and Boros
and they think that that was supposed to
be what the prophecy was about and he's
like oh you know it was no big deal
this whole foreshadowing that Boros
thought that he was going to be the
fulfillment of that he was going to find
a worthy adversary in someone like
Saitama and we're done here
let's go were you able to defeat their
leader yeah he was really strong too
maybe the strongest I've ever faced I
see him so without you master the
prophecy about the destruction of the
earth would come true it's these
prophecies but there are a couple scenes
here at the end the sort of tease Goro
as being the true fulfillment of that
the true villain that's going to lead
the destruction of earth and it's not
going to be a monster it's going to be a
human that thinks of itself as a monster
so as they're walking out of the ship
talking about this big prophecy sasu
maki throws this big tantrum jenos tells
her to shut the hell up she punches him
into a small ball of parts then bang
stops her and very pointedly says that
what's with this behavior with elite
heroes this isn't the way the heroes act
hey Denis say something to her
look spoiled brat shut up and get lost
or pay the price so I'm a brat huh I'm
older than you metal jackass whoa jenos
your next class beat Baldy
that's enough tornado this sort of
behavior isn't becoming of a hero now is
it whatever why are there so many
pigheaded troublemakers amongst the
elite heroes
hey jenos your uh your joints are all
bent the wrong way that's also
foreshadowing for Goro who's a former
disciple of bang so he originally was
trained to become a hero but when all
Anakin Skywalker - bangs obi-wan Kenobi
killing all of his other disciples
Master Skywalker there are too many of
them what are we going to do
[Music]
so was just like Anakin Skywalker during
the Star Wars saga going to the dark
side of the force
killing all the Jedi younglings the big
threat with Kuro is that he's not strong
enough to take Saitama right away but he
adapts and he gives off this fear aura
so lesser heroes are just terrified of
him in his presence but he still gets
his ass handed to him on a regular basis
by Saitama but all that text is teasing
stuff from the Mogga quotes about jenos
about being saitama's discipled like
that's what that post-credits scene was
it was just them teasing that he would
become his disciple and they would start
rebuilding like they rebuilt the hero
association and even though saitama's on
the attack he's back to his normal power
levels mental Knights salvaged the space
ship soon thereafter the hero
association headquarters was
reconstructed and became an impenetrable
Fortress of Steel the infrastructure was
rebuilt with new roads leading out of HQ
this allowed heroes the ability to
deploy quickly to every city
you humans waste your existence and
decadence and gluttony littering the
earth with worthless objects now you
shall rot in the depths of the
underworld that spreads below my mighty
snow who do we have here who you ask
a great man who is a hero for fun and
profit oh great man
with his disciple
come on I'm back to one punch again so
they're sort of balancing the scales a
little bit preparing for the arrival of
Goro there's a lot of quotes about
seeking a worthy adversary they that was
the whole idea of the end of season was
that Boros was seeking a worthy
adversary but he thought that he was the
fulfillment of the prophecy but if he
watched any of my Game of Thrones videos
then you know that prophecy is a tricky
thing people always misinterpreted and I
think early on when they teased the idea
of the prophecy most fans correctly
assumed that there would be some big
left turn and it wouldn't play out
exactly the way the show wanted you to
think that it was going to play out
I do give credit to people that thought
early on that maybe Saitama might
actually be the fulfillment of the
prophecy that he was the danger it was
going to bring about the destruction of
the earth because his powers were so
great and he started to develop the
strange attitude like will I ever find a
worthy opponent like he just seemed so
bored with the idea of being a hero
which is a nice parallel for Goro zark
he was training to become a hero but
didn't identify with humans identified
more with the monsters the funny thing
about that is is that the monster
Association doesn't really like Goro
that much they don't think of him as a
monster because he is a human the other
thing about Goro too though is that he's
really only trained to fight other
humans but you can see why that's
setting him up as the big villain of
season 2 because he'll be fighting the
hero association but he learns very
quickly and can adapt during battles
which i think is going to help him in
his fight against Saitama then by the
end of season 2 he will have learned to
counter saitama's attacks so there's a
lot of foreshadowing for all that stuff
that's going on in banks comments here
at the end of season 1 let me know in
the comments though what do you guys
most hyped about for season 2 it seems
like it's been so long since season 1
happened hopefully we'll get some more
footage before the end of the year but
I'll do another video when they drop
more trailers leave all your requests in
the comments below click here to rewatch
the Dragon Ball super movie trailer and
click here to learn what's going on with
the venom spider-man crossover that's
coming in the future thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight